did i agree with what he said
no everybody goes if you support him
then you must be racist because he's
racist
i'm not racist neither is peace racist
sharon osborne says she's sorry
following wednesday's heated discussion
about piers morgan
on the talk i think we should stop this
and don't try and cry because if anyone
should be crying it should be me
right now i'm talking to a woman who i
believe is my friend
and i don't want anybody here to
to watch this and say that we're
attacking you for being racist
i think it's too late i think that seeds
already sown
while the women of the talk barely
addressed that debate during thursday's
show
we are a tv family here sometimes we
argue like we did yesterday and
sometimes we laugh
but we are back together again today
sharon did take to social media to
apologize
and further explain her point of view
the 68 year old wrote in part
quote to anyone of color that i offended
and
or to anyone that feels confused or let
down by what i said
i am truly sorry i panicked felt
blindsided got defensive
and allowed my fear and horror of being
accused of being racist
take over sharon added that she is not
perfect and is still learning and will
continue to quote learn listen and do
better
she concluded her message writing quote
i hope we can all
hold each other up with accountability
compassion and love during this powerful
time of paving the way for
so much needed change of course this all
comes
after sharon defended piers morgan's
decision to leave good morning britain
got a good chat with itv and um we
agreed to disagree
as well as his comments about meghan
markle following the duchess of sussex's
sit-down with oprah winfrey
i'm sorry i don't believe a word she
says megan martin i wouldn't believe it
if she read my weather report
and the fact that she's fired up
onslaught against our royal family
i think is contemptible at the time
sharon tweeted that she stands by pierce
writing quote people forget that you're
paid for your opinion
and that you're just speaking your truth
i believe in freedom of speech
i believe in the right to be allowed to
have an opinion
that tweet landed sharon in the hot seat
and during wednesday's episode of the
daytime talk show
her co-host tried to explain why people
were upset
he doesn't want to understand that how
megan was treated was racism that
white entitlement privilege that makes
it racist upon itself
once you say i stand by my friend then
then people think well then you must
agree with what he's saying when we kind
of
give passes or give space to people who
are who are being
who are saying damaging harmful things
what we're kind of doing is permissing
it
and i think that's what people are
reacting to
you